LeBron nice Cut and fake and that's
going to be a foul and LeBron James is
holding his right lower foot area
that's not good news
for the Lakers
[Applause]
thank you
the Lakers will not be able to withstand
any kind of prolonged absence
by LeBron James
[Applause]
that's an easy one but like I've seen
him do so many times Doris
when he turns his ankle he'll tie up his
shoe and
be able to finish the game put the cape
on yeah
for 20 years
he back Cuts tries to get Powell off his
feet decides to put it on the deck
it happened on the plant oh he didn't
want to put weight on that right foot so
he makes the move there's the plan oh
see see that ankle
just sort of lean in a little bit but
watch him when he lands he did not want
to come down on that right foot
there was an inadvertent whistle on the
play
there was no foul
he's holding that right foot up so